- Good morning, Believe Nation.
Today's message is focus on the journey.
Over to you, Jessie J.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- I don't ever
disregard the fact that
however hard you work,
it doesn't always guarantee
it's going to happen.
That's the thing that
you have to just believe.
If you don't believe in you,
no one else will even
bother to look at you.
I shoved myself on any
open mics, any gigs.
The amount of stuff.
I've probably done, even up to now,
80, 90% of all my gigs for free.
Surround yourself with
people that you can trust.
people that let you be you.
Compromise, but don't ever
lose what makes you you.
Write from the heart.
Stay happy.
Always remember,
there's always someone worse off than you
and there's always someone
that's working harder than you as well.
When you're asleep,
there's someone grafting.
That's what you have to remember as well,
that for every 10 CD's you send off
there's someone sending off 100.
Just get yourself out
there as much as you can,
and film everything.
That's one thing I've learned.
I'm glad that I did footage for music.
People say to me,
"You've copied so-and-so.
"You've done this, you've done that."
I'm like, "Go on YouTube.
"Five years ago I was singing
"the same songs with the same haircut."
You've got to have fun as well.
Write it down.
Make sure you write it
down, take pictures.
Make sure it's a journey.
The journey is way more
important than where you end up.
That's what you have to remember.
- One of the most popular
questions I get asked is,
"How will I know when I've reached
"one billion entrepreneurs?"
My big goal,
my big vision, mission, what I want to do,
I want to reach a billion entrepreneurs.
I want to know that I'm having
that kind of impact and put out
content and create amazing things
for a ton of entrepreneurs.
I get people asking,
"Well, how will you know
"when you hit a billion entrepreneurs?
"I don't think there's even
"a billion entrepreneurs in the world."
You're missing the point.
I don't actually have a way to track
if I'm hitting a billion entrepreneurs,
and I don't care about it
because I'm not focused on the goal.
I'm focused on the journey.
What it does is make sure that
it aligns me to think about big projects.
Anything that I'm spending
significant time on
I want to make sure has the ability
to reach a lot of people.
I'm making YouTube videos because
it can spread and reach a lot of people.
When I started to write my book,
I wanted to do it with a big publisher,
not just self-publish.
Even though self-publishing
can make me a lot more money,
I went with a big publisher
because I wanted to try to get more reach.
It's the reason why I don't do
business coaching and
one-on-one consulting.
Although it could be really meaningful
and great to have the
one-on-one connection,
I want to do things on a bigger scale.
What that big goal allows me to do
is focus my efforts on the right projects.
I don't actually care about hitting
a billion entrepreneurs.
Just like if I say, "My next
goal on the YouTube channel
"is I want to hit a million subscribers."
It's amazing, it's great.
You get a play button.
We might have another celebration.
As soon as I hit a goal,
I don't really celebrate.
I feel like I need to celebrate
more because, my team,
it's a good thing to do
kind of for team building.
As soon as I hit a goal,
I'm on to the next thing.
I don't take time to celebrate because
the work is the celebration for me.
I want to work more.
I want to get better.
I want to continue to improve.
Hitting a goal and then
saying, "That's it"
is death for me.
For a lot of people, when you hit a goal,
it actually is depressing.
When I sold my first business,
I was 22 years old.
It was a great high.
Great, I sold the company,
but then the next day I had nothing to do.
"What do I,
"what am I supposed to do?
"I have nothing to go to in the morning."
That's a great problem to have.
It's not something I'm complaining about
but it's still a problem.
When you hit a goal
and you don't know what
you're going to do next,
it's depressing.
You don't know what to do every day.
When you don't have a plan
for what to do every day,
it can really drag you down.
I think in doing all these profiles
of different famous entrepreneurs,
people who've had massive success,
yes, it can be great to have a big goal.
It can be great to win an award or
hit a revenue target or
land that big customer or whatever it is.
Go IPO, sell your company,
have some big goal,
but if the goal is the only
thing that's driving you,
it's going to be really hard to make it.
With the most successful people,
the journey is the reward.
The journey of creating
something and marketing it
and you getting better at
it and seeing the impact,
that is the work.
That is the goal.
That is the joy.
That is the excitement.
That is where you derive
your most pleasure from,
not just about hitting some target.
I really challenge you to look at
your life, your business.
Think about what your goals are.
I love setting goals
because when you set a goal,
for me, the most important part of it
is that it starts to align your actions
to achieve that goal.
It's not just about hitting the goal.
It's about those actions.
Those actions are what's going to serve me
to be the best version of me,
to allow me to have the big impact
that I want to have.
Look at your schedule.
Look at what you're doing every day.
Look at your day in, day out,
in your business and in your life.
Do you enjoy
the journey?
For me,
getting married, as an example,
I didn't really care
about the wedding day.
Nina may not be too happy about that,
but she knows.
I didn't really care about the wedding.
It's just another day.
For me,
the excitement,
the energy,
the joy is in the marriage.
It's the everyday.
It's the journey,
not just one day, right?
When you have a kid, it's not just about
the kid being born.
Having a goal to have
a kid, great, amazing.
I have Hayden, almost eight years old.
That was an amazing day,
but it's the journey.
It's the day-to-day.
It's the parenting.
It's everyday, connecting.
That's where you grow,
and that's what you need to enjoy.
If all you're waiting for as a parent
is for your kid to move out,
go to college, get a job,
if all you're waiting for in your marriage
is to hit that 10-year
anniversary or 25-year anniversary
or two-year anniversary or whatever it is,
you're missing out.
The goal is not as important
as the process to get there.
The goal helps you align
yourself so your actions
help you be the best version of you.
I'm not the guy who says, "No goals."
Goals are important.
I love having goals.
I set goals for myself all the time,
but much more important than the goal
is the journey.
The question of the day,
I love your input.
What do you guys think?
Is the goal more important?
Is the journey more important?
Share your thoughts.
Give some more context.
I love to hear what's on your mind.
Share it down in the comments below,
and we'll join in the conversation.
I also want to give a quick
shout-out to Gord Isman.
Gord, thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book Your One Word.
It really, really, really,
really means a lot to me,
and I hope you're enjoying it.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your One Word is,
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot
of espresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going